The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Well, the result of which
we obtained on Wednesday
for spontaneous emission for
the Einstein A coefficient
regarded as an accomplishment
as a highlight of the course.
We've worked hard
to talk about atoms
and electromagnetic fields.
And ultimately, to deal
with spontaneous emission,
it was not enough to put a
semi-classical light atom
interaction, dipole Hamiltonian,
Rabi oscillation and such
to put that into the picture.
We really needed a
quantized version
of the electromagnetic field.
And this is a result when an
atom is excited and interact
with all of the empty
mods of the vacuum.
And be summed up the
probability that photon
is immediate in
any of those modes.
And by doing, kind
of, all of the ever
reaching with
intensity of state,
and for all the possibility
of actions we obtained.
The famous result for the
Einstein A coefficient,
which is also the
natural aligned width
of the atomic excited state.
Do you have any questions
about the derivation
or what we did last week?
Then I think I will just
continue and interpret
the result.
So we go to result for an
Einstein A coefficient.
And well, the question
is, how big is it?
Well it has a
number of constants.
And if it is-- let's discuss
it now in atomic units.
Well, if we assume the
frequency or the energy
is on the order of
Rydberg-- that's
sort of the measure for
an electronic excitation
in the atom-- we assume the
dipole matrix element is one.
That means one per radius.
Since we have pretty much set
everything one and expressed
everything in atomic units, it
means that the speed of light
is-- remember?
The velocity of the atom
in any correspondent
was alpha times smaller
than the speed of light.
But the velocity of the
atom is one atomic unit.
So therefore, the speed
of light in atomic units
is one over alpha.
And that means that if
you look at the formula,
there is the speed of
light to the power of 3
in the denominator.
And that means that
in atomic units
the Einstein A
coefficient is alpha
to the 3, which is 3
times 10 to the minus 7.
So that means that the ratio
of this spontaneous emission
rate, which is also
the inverse lifetime
and, therefore, the natural
alignments of the excited
state.
Relative to the transition
frequency, so the damping
of the harmonic oscillator
or the two level
system relative to the NFC
spacing of the oscillator.
It's small.
It's actually alpha cube.
So if you take this 3
times 10 to the minus 7
and multiply it with the
atomic unit of frequency,
which is 2 Rydbergs.
We obtain on the
order of 10 to 9.
And it's a rate of 10
to the 9 per second.
And that means that the lifetime
of a tubercle atomic level
is on the order of 1 nanosecond.
Well, often it's
10 200 nanosecond
because many transition
frequencies are smaller
by quite a factor than the
atomic unit of the transition
frequency.
Remember, the Rydberg frequency
would be deep in the UV.
But a lot of atoms have
transitions in the visible.
I highlighted already
when I derived it
that the spontaneous emission
has this famous omega cube
dependents.
And that this actually
important to understand
why lower lying levels--
excited hyperfine levels--
do not radiate.
So let me just, kind
of, formalize it.
If I would now estimate what
is the radiative lifetime
for a transition, which is not
as I just assumed in the UV
or in the visible.
Let me estimate what is the
radiative lifetime to emit
a microwave photon
at a few gigahertz?
Well, the microwave frequency
of the gigahertz 10 to the nine
is five orders of magnitude
smaller than the frequency 10
to the 14 of an
optical transition.
So therefore, this is 10
to the 15 times longer.
And if you have,
typically, one or ten
nanosecond for an
electronic transition.
That means that this spontaneous
lifetime for a microwave
transition is seven months.
If in addition we factor in
that hyperfine transitions have
an operator which is a Bohr
magneton and magnetic type
of operator, not an
electric dipole and we
discussed that the Bohr
magneton is actually
when we discuss multiple
transitions we discuss
that the Bohr magneton
is alpha times smaller
than a typical
electric dipole moment.
So therefore, a magnetic
dipole transition
is alpha times weaker than an
electronic dipole transition.
And that means now, if
you multiply months, which
we obtain by the
frequency scaling,
again, by alpha square
for the weakness
of the magnetic dipole, we find
that atomic hyperfine levels
have a lifetime, which is
on the order of 1,000 years.
And this is why it's
very safe to neglect
those transition
in the laboratory
and assume that all hyperfine
states in the ground state
manifold pretty much don't
decay and are long lived.
Questions?
OK, so with that we have
discussed spontaneous emission.
Let's go through a
few clicker questions
to discuss the subject and
verify your understanding.
So the first question
is can an E2 transition,
which is a quadruple
transition, can you
drive it by a plane wave?
Or does it need a
laser beam which
has an intensity gradient
such as a focus laser beam.
Yes or no?
OK.
Well the answer is yes.
You can just use
your laser beam.
If a quadrupole transition
would require a gradient,
it would really
require a gradient
over the size of the atom.
And that would be
extremely hard to achieve.
Fortunately, this is not the
case because what happens
is we actually assumed
in the derivation
that we had a plane
wave into the IKR.
And then do the
tailor expansion.
And it was these part
of the tailor expansion
of a plain wave, which gave
rise to the matrix element
for the quadrupole transition.
So a plane wave laser beam
is sufficient to drive
higher multiple transitions.
Next question.
Can spontaneous
emission be described
as a stimulated emission
process by the zero point field.
So by the zero point field, we
know the electromagnetic wave
is a harmonic oscillator.
And a harmonic oscillator
has a ground state.
And in the ground state
you have zero point motion.
So there is an electric
field, even when
we have the vacuum state.
And the question is,
can spontaneous emission
be described as simply being
stimulated emission but now do
to the silver point fluctuations
of the electromagnetic field.
OK.
The answer is it depends.
It depends if you just want to
make a qualitative hand waving
argument.
Then I would say
you are correct.
You can say that the
electromagnetic field
of the vacuum
stimulates a transition.
But when I said
described, I meant
if you can get it
quantitatively correct.
And there the answer
is actually no
because the energy of
the electromagnetic field
is n plus 1/2 h bar omega.
Whereas, this spontaneous
emission of eight is n plus 1.
So you have half a photon
verse of extra energy.
But this spontaneous
emission is sort
of like the spontaneous
emission is the rate, which
would be stimulated by an
extra energy of h bar omega.
So in other words, you
would get the answer
wrong by a factor of two.
I think decoding deeper in the
electrodynamics description
of spontaneous
emission you would
identify two terms for
spontaneous emission.
One is actually the stimulation
by the vacuum field.
But there is another term
called radiation reaction.
So there's, sort of, two terms.
Trust me.
If not, there are
hundreds of pages
in [INAUDIBLE], which is
books written about it.
And in the ground state, the two
terms destructively interfere.
Therefore, you have no
spontaneous emission
in the current state,
which is reassuring.
But then in the excited
state the two terms
constructively interfere.
And therefore, you get
spontaneous emission,
which is twice as much as
you would get if you just
look at the stimulation
by the vacuum field.
So the answer is not
quantitative but half of it,
yes, can be regarded
as stimulated emission
by the vacuum fluctuations
of the electromagnetic field.
OK.
We emphasized that
spontaneous emission
is proportional to omega cube.
The question is now what is the
dependence in one dimension?
If everything the atom can
only emit in one dimension,
everything is one dimensional,
put the atom into a waveguide.
So your choices are omega cube,
omega square, or omega-- well,
if you press D,
none of the above.
But I can already tell you
it's one of those three.
So everything the same.
But we are in one dimension.
The world seen by the atom and
by the electromagnetic waves
is one dimensional.
Yes, it's correct.
As you remember, out of
the omega cube dependence.
Omega square came from
the density of states.
And what is omega square
in three dimension
becomes omega in two
dimensions and constant density
of state in one dimension.
So therefore, in
one dimension, we
are only left with
the omega dependence.
OK, so there is one
factor of omega,
which does not come from
the density of state.
And the next question is where
does the other power of omega
come from?
As we discussed, it's not
the density of states.
So we have three choices.
One is it comes from the
atomic matrix element,
it comes from the
dipole approximation,
or it comes from
the quantization
of the electromagnetic field.
OK, the majority got it right.
It's a field quantization.
Sort of remember when you
write down the electric dipole
Hamiltonian, in the
quantized version,
there is a perfecter,
which is electric field
of a single photon.
So if you have a
single photon, it
gives rise to an
electric field squared,
which is proportionate
to h bar omega.
And this is, sort of,
the normalization factor.
Two more questions.
We talked a lot about the
rotating wave approximation.
And we also talked about
it for a spinning system
driven by magnetic field.
If you have a rotating
magnetic field,
we do not need the
rotating wave approximation
because if you drive a
spin system with a rotating
magnetic field, we have
only the co-rotating term.
The question I have now for you
is whether the same is correct
or not for an
electronic transition.
So therefore, the question
is for electronic transitions
do we always get the
counter rotating term.
And if you want to have
a simple Hamiltonian,
then we do the rotating
wave approximation.
So the question is is the
rotating wave approximation
necessary because we always
get the counter rotating
term for the
electronic transition,
then the answer is yes.
Or are there examples
where the system is exactly
described by only one term?
The core rotating term.
I will come back to
that later in the class.
But I thought it's
a good question.
OK, let me give you the answer.
I actually coincide with
everybody in the class
here because I would tend to say
no because there are situations
where the counter
rotating term can be zero
due to angular momentum
selection rules.
However, if you have an
electronic transition
and you have a sigma plus
transition to one state,
there's always a possibility
for sigma minus transition.
So you usually get both.
But if you apply an infinitely
strong magnetic field,
then the m equals
minus 1 state can
be moved out of the picture.
You have only, let's say,
the m equals plus 1 state.
And then selection holds mean
that the counter rotating
term is vanishingly small.
But it's an
artificial situation.
So you can all claim
credit for your answer.
Finally, the last question
is about the Lamb shift.
We are now talking about
electronic transitions.
And the question is
Lamb shift-- if it's
due to the counter
rotating term.
In other words, if you have
a situation where the counter
rotating term is
zero, as we just
discussed in the
previous example
that there may be situations.
Somewhat artificially but
you could arrange for it.
The set then implies that
there is no lamb shift.
So yes or no.
Is the lamb shift caused by
the counter rotating term
involved in electronic
transitions?
OK.
OK, well what else
is the lamb shift?
It is the AC stock effect of
the counter rotating term.
So is it due to the
counter rotating term?
Yes, of course.
The lamb shift is
the AC stock effect
caused by the
vacuum fluctuations.
That's what it is.
But we come to
that because I want
to discuss later today
some aspects of the fully
quantized Hamiltonian.
And we will, again, in the
fully quantized picture
see the operators,
which are responsible
for the core rotating for
the counter rotating turn.
And then I will point
to the operator,
which causes a lamb shift.
But before I continue, any
questions about the questions?
Collin.
AUDIENCE: When you derive the
amplitude in the electric field
due to the single photon--
PROFESSOR: Yep.
AUDIENCE: I always get
the factor of two wrong.
So you wrote h bar omega is 2
epsilon 0 [INAUDIBLE] squared.
Now there's a contribution that
comes from the electric field
and magnetic field because
you have one factor of two.
Then there's always that
other factor of two.
Are you getting that
from using one half h
bar because of the
vacuum fluctuation.
PROFESSOR: I'm not going
back to the formula
because I run the risk
that it was wrong.
But all I want to say is what
I really mean is use Jackson.
Put in a volume V-- an
electromagnetic field--
with h bar omega energy.
And the electric field
squared of this photon,
that's what I mean.
And if you find a factor of
two mistakes in my E square,
I can still, you know,
get out of theory exit
by the rear-entrance door
by saying that there is also
a difference whether E
square is E square RNS
or whether E square
is the amplitude.
You know I mean there are risk
factors of two everywhere.
But what I mean is
really the electric field
caused by one photon.
And of course, the
argument stands.
I don't need any factors
of two or any subtleties
of the electromagnetic
field energy.
We know that the energy is
n plus 1/2 but emission is
n plus 1.
And these shows that the
stimulation by the vacuum field
cannot quantitatively account
for spontaneous emission.
AUDIENCE: So the quantity
that you set equal to
is h bar omega 1/2, not the
fluctuation but the real--
PROFESSOR: OK, if
you want to know,
let's not compare
apples with oranges.
You want an electric field.
And you can pick whether
it's the RMS field
or whether it is the
maximum amplitude.
You can pick what you want.
But now we are comparing
what is the e-square
for the vacuum-- for
single-mode-- vacuum.
And what is the e-square
for single photon?
The two answers differ
by a factor of 2.
A single photon
is twice as strong
in e-square as the vacuum
fluctuations in the same mode.
That's what it means.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about the quantum emission
rate.
The explanation that it had--
quantum mechanic derivation
that we have, do people
not know the formula,
how to describe spontaneous
emission [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: I think so.
I have not gone deeply
back into the story.
But a lot of credit
is given to Einstein.
And as I mentioned last
week that Einstein actually
had spontaneous emission in his
derivation for the Einstein A
and B coefficient in
this famous paper.
And so he found that there must
be spontaneous emission based
on a thermodynamic argument.
It's only spontaneous
emission, which
brings the internal population
of an atom into equilibrium.
So I think it is correct to say.
AUDIENCE: Can you derive it
from that stagnant condition
of getting [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: That's
what Einstein did.
And the answer is, by
comparison with the Planck law,
you get an expression for the
Einstein A and B coefficient.
Now of course, you can
go the other way around.
You can see if you just use
classical physics you would
actually expect--
now it depends.
If you use the Bohr
model, you would
expect that the electron is
radiating and it was a mystery.
How can you have an atom
in the ground state, which
is circling around a nucleolus,
and not radiating at all?
On the other hand,
in quantum mechanics,
we are not assuming that
the atom is circulating.
And we have an
accelerated charge
and then we have a time
dependent charge distribution.
We use the steady
state wave function.
So I'm not sure
if there is maybe
an argument, which
would say there should
be some spontaneous
emission based
on a purely classic argument.
But this would not
be the whole story
because a classic argument would
then deal with the difficulty.
Why is there
difference between n
equals 1, which does not radiate
in n equals 2, which radiates.
So my understanding is
that it is only the physics
either through the
perspective of Einstein
by just using equilibration
or our microscopic derivation
using filed quantization,
which allows us to understand
the phenomenon of a
spontaneous emission.
Other questions?
OK, then before we talk about
some really cute and nice
aspects of the fully
quantised Hamiltonian,
I want to spend a
few minutes talking
about degeneracy factors.
I've already given
you my opinion.
You should not think in
almost all situations
about levels, which
have a degeneracy.
Just think about states.
A state is a state,
and it counts as one.
And if you have a level which
has triple degeneracy, well,
it has three states.
Just kind of count the states
and look at the states.
However, there are
formula for which
involves degeneracy factors.
And just to remind you,
when we had the discussion
of Einstein's A
and B coefficient,
the Einstein A coefficient
was proportionate to the B
coefficient responsible
for stimulated emission
from the excited to
the ground state.
But the Einstein B
coefficient for absorption
was related to the
Einstein B coefficient
for stimulated
emission by involving
these degeneracy factors.
So degeneracies appear
and in some formal layer
that it makes a lot
of sense to use them.
So I've always said for a
fundamental understanding,
you should just assume
all degeneracies are one.
This is how you
can avoid, sort of,
some baggage in
deriving equations.
And I'm still standing
to my statement.
I want to show you
now a situation
where it becomes useful to
consider degeneracy factors.
So let me give you an example.
We can now look at the situation
where we have an excited P
state and a ground
state, which is S.
Or I can look at the
opposite situation
where we have an S state,
which can radiate to a P state.
Well by symmetry, the
different p states
and plus 1 and minus
1 m equals 0 are just
connected by spatial rotations.
So therefore, their
lifetime of the 3 P states
and the rate of spontaneous
emission are the same.
But if you now assume
that you have absorption,
you go from the S
state to the P state.
Then you find that the
Einstein B coefficient there
are now three possible ways.
Not just one polarization
or 3 polarization.
And you will find that this is
proportional to three times r.
However, in this
situation, it's a reverse
but let me just finish here.
So here the natural
align rates and the rate
of stimulated emission
described by the coefficient
from the excited state
to the ground state
is proportionate to R.
Whereas, in the other situation,
if you have absorption now,
well, each of those levels,
there's only one transition,
one pass way.
Therefore, you will find that
the coefficient for absorption
is proportionate to
R. Whereas, gamma
and the stimulated
emission, which is now BSP,
is proportionate to
three R because there
are three pathways.
So depending what the situation
is, you have to be careful.
And you would say-- but if
it's an S to P transition,
it maybe connected by
the same matrix element.
And therefore, you would
say shouldn't there
be align strings,
which is independent
whether you go from S to P or
P to S, which just describes
in a natural way what is really
the coupling between S and P
state?
And yes indeed, there
is in the literature
some definition of line
strings where the lines strings
S would be proportionate
to the sum of all
of the eights between an
initial and the final state.
And do sum over all.
So therefore, when you use this
formula for the line strings,
whether you have the
situation on the left side
or on the right side,
you will do always
the sum over the 3
possible transitions.
So the lines things is the
same for both situations.
It's just generic for
an S to P transition.
So if you use this
definition but then you
have the situation that
spontaneous emission is always
given by the line
strings but you
have to multiply now by the
multiplicity of the excited
state.
If you have a P state,
the whole line strings
is distributed
over three states.
And each state has only a
spontaneous emission rate,
which is a third of what
the line strings gives you.
I don't want to
beat it to death,
because I hate
degeneracy factors.
But I just thought this
example with the P to S
and S to P transition tells
you why they necessarily
have to appear in derivations
like Einstein's A and B
coefficient.
I hope there are no further
questions about degeneracies.
But you know, making
this comment also
allows me to say, well, when
I derived the Einstein A
coefficient-- what we did
last class-- I did not
use any degeneracy factors.
Well, this is correct.
Our derivation
assumed that there
was-- we assumed that there
is only one final state.
We did not include
degeneracy factors.
We also assumed that
we had a dipole matrix
element, which was
along the z-axis.
And so by those definitions,
I have implicitly
picked a geometry,
which can be represented
by that we have
an exciting piece
state in the m equals 0 state.
And we have a pie transition
with linear polarization
to this s state.
And by doing that,
I did not have
to account for any degeneracies.
But in general, if you
derive microscopically
an equation for
spontaneous emission,
you may have to take into
account that your excited
state has different
transitions-- sigma plus
and sigma minus transitions--
to different states.
And you have to
be careful how you
do the sum over all
possible finer states.
And this is where degeneracies
would eventually matter?
Questions?
OK, so then lets go from
P counting or accounting
for the number of
states to something,
which is hopefully
more exciting.
We want to talk about the
fully quantized Hamiltonian.
So what we are
working towards now
and it may spill over
into the Wednesday class
is I want to give you the
sort of paradigmatic example
of cavity QED where an atom
within an excited state
is in an empty cavity.
And now it can emit a photon
into the mortification
mode of the cavity.
But these photon
can be reabsorbed.
So this is a phenomenon of
vacuum Rabi oscillations.
And so I want to set up
the Hamiltonian and then
the equation to
demonstrate to you
the vacuum Rabi oscillations.
And for me, the vacuum
Rabi oscillations
are the demonstration,
that spontaneous emission,
has no randomness,
no spontaneity,
so to speak because you can
observe coherent oscillation.
A coherent time evolution
of the whole system
and which is possible only
due to spontaneous emission.
So let's go there.
So just to make the
connection, a few lectures ago,
we had a semi
classical Hamiltonian.
This is when I
wanted to show you
that the two level electronic
system can be mapped
onto a spin one half system
driven by magnetic field.
So this was when we only
looked at the stimulated term
when we only did
perturbation theory.
And in that situation, we had
the electronic excitation.
And then we had the
drive field, which
was assumed to be purely
classical like a rotating
magnetic field which drives
spin up spin down transitions
magnetically.
And we concluded that, yes,
if you use a laser field,
it does exactly the same
to a two level atom what
a magnetic field does
to spin up spin down.
But now we are one step further.
We've quantized the
electromagnetic field.
And we have
spontaneous emission.
And this is something, for
reasons I just mentioned,
you will never find
in spin up spin down
because it will take 1,000
years for spontaneous emission
to happen.
So now we want to actually
go beyond this semi classical
picture, which is fully
analogous to the precession
and rotation of the spin
in a magnetic field.
And we want to add
spontaneous emission.
So what we had here
is the Rabi frequency
was a matrix element--
the dipole matrix
element-- times a
classic electric field.
And we want to replace that
now by the electric field
at the position of the atom.
But we want to use the
fully quantized version
of the electric field.
And it also becomes useful to
look at the sigma x operator,
which actually has two matrix
elements of [INAUDIBLE], which
connects ground excited
and excited ground state.
And one of them is going from
the excited to the ground
state.
So this is, sort of,
lowering the energy
to sigma minus operator.
And the other one will
be a raising operator.
It raises the
excitation of the atom.
And we will refer
to it as sigma plus.
So the electric
field is replaced
by the operator obtained from
the fully quantized picture.
Here we have the
prefactor, which
is the electric field of a
single photon or half a photon,
whatever.
But it's factors of
2 r square over 2.
We have the polarization.
And now if you would
take the previous result
and would look at it.
Well we want to go to
the Schrodinger picture.
And I mentioned that in
the Schrodinger picture
the operators are
time independent.
So we cancelled the e
to the i omega t term.
If you would go to the
result we had last week
and would simply get rid of
the e to the i omega t term,
you would now find
operators a and dagger.
But they would have factors
of i in front of it.
That's a equation we
had when we derived it.
Well I prefer note to use
something which looks nicer.
Just use a and a dagger.
And you can obtain it by
shifting the origin of time.
So we're not looking e to
the i omega t or t equals 0.
We wait a quarter period into e
to the i omega t just gives us
factors of i, which conveniently
cancel the other factors of i.
So what I'm doing is
just for convenience.
And let me write down that this
is in the Schrodinger picture.
OK.
So we want to absorb all
constant by in one constant
now, which is the single
photon Rabi frequency.
We have the type or matrix
element of the atom.
There's a dot product with
the polarization of the light.
And then we have the
electric field amplitude
of a single photon.
h bar omega over 2 epsilon 0 v.
So this is what appears
in the coupling.
And we want to write it
s h bar omega 1 over 2.
And this omega 1 is the
single photon Rabi frequency.
And with that, we have
now a Hamiltonian,
which is really a classic
Hamiltonian, written down
in the standard form.
It has the excitation energy
times the sigma z matrix.
It has the single
photon Rabi frequency.
The single photon Rabi
frequency appears.
You know, this is the single
photon Rabi frequency.
But then the operator
for the electric field,
after getting rid off the i's,
is simply h plus h dagger.
h plus h dagger.
So this takes care
of the photon field.
And the operator which
acts on the atoms
are the raising and lowering
operator sigma plus and sigma
minus.
And finally, we have
the Hamiltonian,
which describes the
photon field which
is h bar omega times a dagger
a the photon number operator.
Any questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: I mean,
we are looking
at the interaction with an atom,
which is at rest at the origin.
Therefore, e to the ikr is 0.
We will only consider
the spatial dependence e
to the ikr when we
allow the atom to move.
As long as the atom is
stationary for convenience,
we put the atom at i equals 0.
But in 8.422 when we talk about
light forces and laser cooling,
then it becomes essential
to allow the photon to move.
And this is actually where the
recoil and the light forces
come into play.
But as long as we're not
interested in light forces,
only in the internal dynamics--
calm and excited state--
we can conveniently neglect
our spatial dependencies.
Other questions?
So this is really a
famous Hamiltonian.
And you also see how
natural the definition
of the single-photon
Rabi frequency.
So we have one half h bar
omega for the diagonal sigma z
matrix.
This is the atomic excitation.
This is the unperturbed
Hamiltonian of the atom.
Hamiltonian of the photon.
And now the two are coupled.
And the coupling is a
product of an operator acting
on the photon field
plus minus one photon.
And the other one is an
operator acting on the atoms.
And it is plus, minus,
and atomic excitation.
So let me just
remind you of that.
The sigma plus and
sigma minus operator.
The sigma plus is the
atomic raising operator,
which takes a ground
to the excited state.
And the sigma minus operator is
the atomic lowering operator,
which takes the atom from the
excited to the ground state.
So this is our Hamiltonian.
And to hear about space on
which this Hamiltonian acts
is the product
space of the atom.
Direct product of the
states of the light.
Or in other words,
the basis state
would be that we
use for the atoms.
The states which have zero
or one quantum of excitation.
So we use excited
state or ground state.
And for the photon, we can
just use the Fock states
where the occupation
number is n.
Questions about that?
So it's a very-- just look
at it with some enjoyment
for a few seconds.
I mean, this is a Hamiltonian,
which has just a few terms.
But what is behind
it is, of course,
a power of all the definitions.
I mean, each symbol
has so much meaning.
But in the end, by having
this formalism of operators
quantized electromagnetic field.
We can write down-- we can
catch many, many aspects
or we can, pretty much, fully
describe how a two level
system interacts a quantized
electromagnetic field
with that set of equations.
Of course, the fact is not
that everything is so simple.
The fact is that we have, by
understanding the physics,
we have skillfully
made definitions,
which allow us to
write everything down
in this compact form.
So often something is
simple to write down.
But if there's a lot
of physics insight,
we spend some time
in discussing it.
And the first thing I want
to just point out and discuss
is this interaction term.
We have the product of
sigma plus and sigma
minus with a and a dagger.
So what we have here is we
have an interaction term.
And this interaction part
has actually four terms
in a very natural way.
Well, let me just
write them down.
It's sigma plus with a.
Sigma minus with a dagger.
Sigma plus with a dagger.
And sigma minus with a.
OK, so let's discuss those.
Sigma plus with a dagger.
Sigma plus is actually
an absorption process.
a reduces the photo
number by one,
and increases the
atomic excitation
from the column to
the excited state.
The other term looks naturally,
intuitively like emission.
The a dagger operator takes
us from n to n plus 1.
And sigma minus takes us
from the excited state
to the current state.
So these are the
two terms, which
we would call intuitive terms
because they make sense.
The other terms are
somewhat more tricky.
Sigma plus and a dagger
means we create a photon
and we create an excitation.
So in other words, it's not
that, like the other term,
quantum of excitation disappears
from the field, appears
in the atom, and vice versa.
Sigma plus a dagger means
we have an atom excitation
takes us from the ground
to the excited state.
Plus, we emit a photon
at the same time.
And sigma minus a
dagger means that we
go from the excited
to the ground state.
So we have an atom d excitation.
And I would say,
well, if the atom
is d excited it
should emit a photon.
But instead, the
photon disappears.
So we have those processes.
The last two are
sometimes referred to
in the theoretical literature.
They are off shell.
Under shell is
energy conservation.
Off shell means they
cannot conserve energy.
But nevertheless,
these are terms
which appear in the operator.
But you should be used to
if you have often terms
in the operator which cannot
drive a resonant transition.
When you looked at the DC
stock effect or when we looked
at the AC stock effect
for low frequency photons,
those low frequency photons
cannot excite an atom
to the excited state.
So they are not
causing a transition,
but they led to energy shifts
in second order perturbation
theory.
So therefore, those terms
this language now cannot drive
transitions.
They can only drive transitions
to virtual states, which
would mean they can only appear
in second order perturbation
theory that you go up to
a so-called virtual state
but you immediately go down.
And those terms give
only rise to shifts.
No transitions because you
couldn't conserve energy
in the transition.
But you can do shifts
in second order.
And one example, which we
discussed in the clicker
question is that those shifts
are actually lamb shifts.
And in other places,
especially in the context
of microwave fields, they are
called Bloch-Siegert shifts
And let's just look
at one specific state.
And this is the simplest of all.
We have the vacuum no photons.
And the atom is in
the ground state.
If you look at the
four possibilities
of the interaction term, there
is only one non vanishing term.
The photon is at the bottom
off all possible states.
The atom is at the bottom
of the possible states.
So when we act with
the four terms on it,
the only term which
contributes is
where those is where
those are raised
because all the others are 0.
The only non vanishing
term is where
we create a virtual
atomic excitation and also
a virtual excitation
of the photon field.
And we know that when we
have an atom in the ground
state in the vacuum that
the only manifestation
of the electromagnetic
field is, of course, not
spontaneous emission
but the lamb shift.
So therefore, if you
would apply this operator
to the bound state of
an electron in an atom,
the complicated 1s wave
function of hydrogen and sum
this operator over all modes
of the electromagnetic field.
Then you would have done
a first principle QED
calculation of the lamb shift.
I'm not doing it but
you should understand
that this operator--
sigma plus a dagger--
is you operator
for the Lamb shift.
Questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Oh,
no, everything is.
If you have a two level
system, this Hamiltonian
captures everything
which appears in nature
if you have a two level
system interacting
with the electromagnetic field.
That's it.
A radiation reaction
is just something
we can pull out of here.
Stimulated emission we
can pull out of here.
The way how vacuum fluctuations
create a lamb shift or the way
how vacuum fluctuations affect
an atom in the excited state,
everything is included in here.
The question is just
can we solve it.
And the calculations
can get involved.
But this is the
full QED Hamiltonian
for a two level system.
That's a full picture.
I mean, that's why I sort of
said before be proud of it.
You understand the full picture
of how two level systems
interact with
electromagnetic radiation.
The only complication is, yes,
if you put more levels into it
and such and things can
get richer and richer.
And-- yes, we have also made
the dipole approximation,
which we're just wondering
how critical it is.
Well, we use the electric
field a and a dagger,
but my gut feeling is it doesn't
really matter what we have.
Here is the most generic term,
which can create and annihilate
photons, and we have
the a and a dagger term.
Actually, I don't
know what would
happen if you don't make
the dipole approximation.
Well, if you have
two levels which
are coupled by magnetic
dipole, then you
have the same situation.
It is just your prefactor, the
semi photon Rabi frequency,
is now alpha times smaller
because of the smaller dipole
matrix element.
So I think you can pick, pretty
much, any level you want.
And this is why I actually
discussed matrix elements
at the beginning of the unit.
For, pretty much,
all of the discussion
you're going to have,
it doesn't really
matter what kind of
transition you have as long
as the transition creates
or annihilates a photon.
And all the physics of the
multiplicity of the transition,
magnetic, dipole, electric,
quadrupole, or whatever
just defines what this the
semi photon Rabi frequency is.
You've put me on the
spot, but the only thing
which comes to my mind now
is if you would formulate QED
not in the dipole approximation
but through with the p
minus a formulation.
Then we have an a-square term.
And then we have the
possibility that one transition
can emit two photons.
So that's not included here.
AUDIENCE: So that's higher--
PROFESSOR: This would be
something higher order.
On the other hand,
we can shoulder
the canonical
transformation that the p
minus a formalization
with the a-square term
is equivalent to
dipole approximation.
So the question whether
you have a transition which
emits two photons simultaneously
or two photons sequentially
eventually by going
through an immediate state,
this is not a
fundamental distinction.
You can have one description
of your quantum system
via two photons automated
in one transition.
You have another description
of your quantum system where
photons cannot-- only one
photon can be emitted.
And then you have to lend
an intermediate state.
And you would say, well,
either two photons at once
or one photon at a time.
This is two different
kinds of physics.
But we can show that the
two pictures are connected
with economical transformation.
So therefore, you have
two descriptions here.
But anyway, I'm going a little
bit beyond my knowledge.
I'm just telling you
bits and pieces I know.
But this Hamiltonian is
either generally exact.
I just don't know
how to prove it.
But it really captures
in all of the QED aspects
of the system we
want to get into.
So OK.
So in many situations
we may decide
that the off shell
terms of the interaction
just create level shifts, Lamb
shifts, Bloch-Siegert shifts.
And we may simply
absorb those lamb shifts
in our atomic energy
levels, omega e and omega g.
So therefore, for the
dynamic of the system,
if you include all
of those lamb shifts
in the atomic description, you
do not need those off shell
counter intuitive terms.
These are actually also
the counter-rotating terms
in the semi classical
approximation.
We only keep the
intuitive terms.
And that's called, again, the
rotating wave approximation.
Just to remind you, we do
not have rotating waves here.
Everything is operators.
But the same kind of physics--
co- and counter-rotating--
appears here that
we have four terms.
Two are the fully
quantized version
of the co-rotating terms.
And the other two--
the off shell terms--
are the quantized version of
the counter rotating term.
So therefore, if you neglect
those two off shell terms,
we have now the fully
quantized Hamiltonian
in the rotating
wave approximation.
So let me just write it
down because it's also
a beautiful line.
We have the electronic system.
We have the interaction
Hamiltonian,
which has now owned
the two terms.
When we raise the
atomic excitation,
we lower the photon
excitation and vice versa.
And we have the Hamiltonian for
the photon field a dagger a.
And this is apart from
those lamb shift terms.
The full QED description
of the system.
And if we only consider
one mode-- here, of course,
in general, the
general Hamiltonian
has to be sent over a modes.
And then you'll get spontaneous
emission and everything
we want.
But if you have a
situation where you only
look at one single
mode, then you have what
is called the famous
chains Cummings model
And very important result
of this James Cummings model
are the vacuum
Rabi oscillations,
which I want to discuss now.
OK.
So let me just-- it's
called James Cummings Model.
So let me describe to
you why it is a model.
Well it assumes a
two level system,
which we find a lot of
candidates among the atoms
we want.
Sure our atoms have
hyperfine states.
But we can always
select a situation
where, essentially, we
only couple two states.
We can prepare initial
state by optical pumping,
and then use circularly
polarized slide
on a cycling transition.
And this is how we prepare
in the laboratory a two level
system.
So that's one assumption of this
model with a two level system.
But the second assumption
is that the atom only
interacts with a similar mode.
And that requires a
little bit of engineering
because it means
we need a cavity.
So let me just
set up the system.
So our laboratory is
a big box of volume
v. And this is where we maybe
quantize electromagnetic field
to calculate
spontaneous emission.
And our atom here
may actually decay
with the rate gamma, which
is given by the Einstein A
coefficient.
And in order to describe
this spontaneous emission,
be quantized electromagnetic
field in the large volume v.
But now we have a
cavity with two mirrors.
And those two mirrors
define one mode
of the electromagnetic
field, which
will be in resonance on your
resonance with the atom.
Well there will be some losses
out of the cavity, which
eventually coupe the
electromagnetic mode
inside the cavity to the other
awards modes in the speaker
volume v. And this is
described by a cavity damping
constant kappa.
What is also important is when
we use cavity to single out one
mode of the
electromagnetic field,
the cavity volume is v prime.
And we often make it very
small by putting the atoms
in the cavity where the mirror
spacing is extremely small.
OK.
We know, and I'm not
writing it down again,
what the Einstein
A coefficient is.
The Rabi frequency-- the
single photon Rabi frequency--
which couples the atom to
the one mode of the cavity
has this important
perfecter, which
was or is the electric field
of one photon in the cavity.
And importantly, it
involves the electric field
of the photon in the cavity
value, which is B prime.
So now in addition
to using, you know--
now you see what our
experimental handle is.
If you make this
volume very small,
then we can enter this
strong coupling regime
where the single photon Rabi
frequency for this one mode
selected by the cavity
becomes much larger then
the spontaneous emission into
all the many other modes.
So the interaction with
one mode due to the cavity
and the smallness of
the volume is, sort of,
outperforming all these many,
many modes of the surroundings.
And that would mean that
an atom in an excited state
is more likely to emit into
the mode between the two
cavity mirrors than to any
other modes to the side.
Secondly, of course,
when the photon
has been emitted
into the cavity,
the photon can still
couple to the other modes
by cavity losses kappa.
And now we assume that we have
such high reflectivity mirrors
that kappa is smaller that the
single photon Rabi frequency.
And this is called the strong
coupling regime of cavity QED.
So then we can at least
observe for a limited time
the interplay between a single
mode of the cavity and a two
level system.
And this is a James
Cummings model.
The James Cummings model.
So in that situation,
the Hamiltonian,
the fully quantized Hamiltonian,
and the QED Hamiltonian couples
only pairs of states
which we label
those states the manifold n.
So we have an excited
state with n photons.
And it is coupled to the ground
state with one more photon.
Our Hamiltonian has
two coupling terms.
Remember the other tool where
you clicked it in the rotating
wave approximation and we
can go from left to right
with sigma minus a data plus.
And we can go from right to left
with the operator sigma plus
and the annihilation
of the [INAUDIBLE] a.
So as long as we have
a detuning delta,
which is relatively small.
As long as detuning is small,
the rotating wave approximation
is excellent.
So let me just conclude
by writing down
the Hamiltonian for the
situation I just discussed.
And then we'll discuss the
Hamiltonian on Wednesday.
So if this is energy,
we have two levels.
The excited state
with n photons,
the ground state with
n plus 1 photons.
If the photons are on resonance,
the two levels are degenerate.
But if you have
a detuning delta,
the two levels are
split by delta.
And what we are doing right
now is for the [INAUDIBLE]
the Hamiltonian,
we shift the origin
so the zero of the
energy is just halfway
between those two states.
That's natural.
So this avoids just off
sets in our equations.
So our Hamiltonian
has now the splitting
of plus minus delta over two.
The coupling has the perfecter,
which is the single photon Rabi
frequency.
And then the a
and a dagger terms
depends on n square
root n plus 1.
So what I wrote down now is
the Hamiltonian rotating wave
approximation, which
interacts, which
describes only one
pair of states.
But we have sort of a
cause in our Hilbert space.
One pair of states
for each label n.
But each of them is,
sort of, described
by the decoupled Hamiltonian.
So that's what I wanted
to present you today.
And I will show you on Wednesday
how this Hamiltonian needs
to Rabi oscillations not
induced by an external field
but induced by the vacuum.
Any questions?